monster trucks is directed by Chris
wedge who made Ice Age robots and epic
and this is his first big foray into
live-action in this film is about a guy
who works for a truck parts warehouse of
sorts basically a junkyard and after an
evil oil company lets loose some aliens
that were deep within the ground
this alien attaches itself to a monster
truck and helps our hero drive a big
monster truck in really epic action
scenes now if I'm being completely
honest I didn't go into this movie
expecting much it's January
this is a movie about an alien squid
monster that can drive monster trucks
and do really cool tricks and our hero
gets to drive the big truck and there's
a poor desperate girl at the school who
keeps giving affections to this guy even
though he has no interest in her so yeah
I really didn't think this movie was
gonna be any good and I wasn't really
excited about seeing it that I don't
think a lot of people are either but
surprisingly monster trucks is not awful
this is not like max steel level bad
this isn't like a disappointments room
or a 9lives it is my kind of January
movie this is a perfectly watchable
disposable mediocre bad film this is not
a good movie but it is not awful this is
actually fairly competently directed and
the acting and the musical score and
everything kind of combines to make a
movie that I think young kids will
really enjoy but beyond that this film
doesn't have much under the hood so to
speak so sorry so our main hero in this
movie is Tripp played by Lucas Hill he
befriends this alien squid monster and
also befriends Meredith played by Jane
levy now this girl loves Tripp I mean
she is all over him for the first half
of this movie and he doesn't give her
the time of day is this just like the
most desperate girl in North Dakota
these are both very attractive people
there's nobody else in North Dakota for
you they're just gonna follow this boy
around despite the fact that he treats
her like a complete ass for almost this
entire film she is at his beck and call
it's kind of dumb
actually I was one of my least favorite
aspects of this movie as for the squid
monster which they eventually
affectionately call Creech he was okay I
mean the CG is actually not too bad it's
it's fine for what it is my biggest
issue with monster trucks is that every
character is perfectly fine with murder
I get that the main villain the big evil
guy that chases them everywhere he's
perfectly fine with killing everybody
and destroying this race of alien
creatures because it just might damage
their oil supply they're afraid of the
government finds out that there's this
race of aliens beneath their oil rig
company that they'll shut the oil
company down so that's that's the big
the big scheme you know the big
government scheme that's in all of these
movies because it's it's you know it's
its et basically with a monster truck
but like I said this is a kids movie I
get if they make the big villain look
really over-the-top but our main hero
the first time he goes out onto the road
with Creech inside his monster truck
driving the truck for him he crashes
into like five or six people he causes a
lot of fairly substantial car accidents
and never really looks back to check if
he's hurt anyone or if anyone's okay and
even worse towards the end of the movie
there's a semi truck that's carrying
something they need to stop him he's not
like a big villain he's just some worker
in fact I don't even think you ever see
their driver they do this big epic jump
scene and literally topple the
semi-truck turn it upside down and this
thing crashes and skids across the dirt
and you're like that guy might be dead I
guess it's okay though cuz everyone
drives off and we're happy and and no
one checks it's not like he was a big
villain he was just some driver who had
something in the semi they needed
there's so many scenes like that in this
film where monster trucks are just
plowing into a whole bunch of civilians
or other workers and you're like are all
of these people dying it's not the
greatest thing for kids to see because
it sort of teaches you that there's no
consequences for your actions especially
when there's no jail time for anybody at
the end of this movie no spoilers but
it's like really these kids did some
serious law-breaking here this is my
best way to describe monster trucks if I
was like seven years old when this movie
came out and I saw it in theaters I
probably have really good memories with
that event and then when the big white
clamshell VHS tape comes out I'd
probably buy it
and I'd probably watch there a lot and
enjoy it a lot and then right around age
like 12 to 13
I'd be like this movie ain't that great
I want to watch ET and I think a lot of
kids will probably have that experience
with monster trucks it's not awful it's
actually fairly competently made and
some of the performances are okay but
beyond that I'm gonna give monster
trucks a c-minus guys thank you so much
as always for watching I got reviews
coming up very soon for you if you could
see my background is x-men defied
because my buddy the flick pick is
visiting and we're doing a collaboration
involving x-men leading up to Logan I'm
really excited about that look forward
to that guys I also have reviews for the
bye bye man coming tomorrow and
sleepless with Jamie Foxx thanks very
much guys and if you liked this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]